not many weapons in the Star Wars Galaxy
can hold up to a lightsaber but there's
little Reckoning with the few that can
so who's got the tools to bring down a
Jedi the blade of Tarzan is a robust
looking ornamental sword that looks like
a cross between a Japanese Katana and a
saber this weapon is something of a
history in the Star Wars Universe mother
Towson is an important antagonistic
figure in the Clone Wars one who proves
to be a physical force to be reckoned
with when she takes on Jedi Master
mate's window for this purpose she
conjures thousand sword an eerie looking
blade that radiates green magical icore
and proves to be on par with Windu's
iconic purple lightsaber it's a neat
trick really the fact that mother Towson
can I instantly summon a sword that's
able to match a lightsaber means that
she doesn't need to carry a weapon
instead she can simply create one when
necessary which makes it next to
impossible to the summer what's more
night sisters can use their magical icor
to create all sorts of solid objects
which means that the blade of thousand
in Ahsoka May refer to thousand's
technique of summoning a sword instead
of the object itself hence it's slightly
different appearance a magic blade
doesn't need to be carried around and
there's no technology to maintain which
makes it far more useful than a
lightsaber if there's a drawback to this
particular weapon it seems to be fairly
difficult to summon what takes thousand
and me a moment clearly requires
concentration from the three great
mothers still since the Clone Wars
villain clearly has enough mystical
juice to create a lightsaber level
weapon when the situation so requires
thousand sword more than earns its place
in Star Wars Legend the blade of
thousand isn't the first weapon Morgan
ellsbeth is used against Ahsoka Tano
their first meeting in the Mandalorian
culminates in a samurai style Showdown
during which Morgan wields a very nice
looking metal spear as Ahsoka soon finds
out this weapon is made of high quality
beskar the Mandalorian steel that's
resistant to just about anything
including lightsabers much like in
Ahsoka Morgan's actual fighting skills
are no match for her opponent although
that's not her weapon's fault the best
gas spear is more than able to match the
lightsabers and its way to reach make
Morgan's attacks particularly dangerous
she even manages to partially disarm
Ahsoka this scene makes it clear that a
Bhaskar weapon has the potential to be
very dangerous to a lightsaber user
this is the way
once more the metal can be used to make
all sorts of objects and Equipment
Morgan spear is just one of the many
possible beskar melee weapons for
instance the armorer from the
Mandalorian uses her Bhaskar gravity
hammer and tongues to deadly effect in
combat and the Star Wars Legends law
makes mention of a traditional machete
style short sword known as bascad which
is often dual wielded with a dagger
called a cow apart from its Shia
versatility pure beska also has one
additional advantage over the legendary
Jedi weapon lightsabers are unable to
damage bescar armor but good beskar
weapons have no such problem
Star Wars often presents Mass soldiers
as simply disposable cannon fodder the
elite praetorian guard is a notable
exception to this rule however known for
guarding supreme leader snoke's throne
room in The Last Jedi the imposing red
armored first order super soldiers are
clearly bad news from the get-go and
thus before you even see their melee
Arsenal the praetorians wield various
exotic weapons that have been fitted
with Electro plasma blades that enable
them to withstand lightsaber strikes
these include a brutal looking blade
staff known as fibrovals as well as a
bicento spear a nasty chain whip a vibro
arbia blade that can be used as two
separate weapons or a single one with
blades on both ends the praetorian guard
is ultimately no match against a
powerful Duo of Rey and kylo ren but
it's a far closer fight than most
battles against Master goons than a Star
Wars Universe a lot of this has to do
with the villain's weapons which they
cleverly use on several occasions to
make their opponents lives extremely
difficult the chain whip in particular
manages to temporarily incapacitate
Rey's lightsaber in a way that could
easily have killed her the first order
era praterian guard is an evolution of
the Imperial praetorian God members of
which have been known to wield similar
custom Weaponry judging by the fact that
they take down past Vizsla in the
Mandalorian the franchise clearly wants
fans to know that these guys are no
pushovers either when the force awakens
brought the Skywalker Saga back to the
big screen few people could have
expected that one of the most glorious
moments in the movie would come courtesy
of a random angry first order
Stormtrooper you remember the scene Finn
wields a lightsaber in battle against
his former comrades on takadana suddenly
one of the Stormtroopers loudly calls
him a traitor dramatically throws away
his Blaster and ride shield and whips
out a huge high-tech melee weapon he
then proceeds to fight Finn and it
quickly becomes clear that the trooper's
weapon can withstand lightsaber blows
Finn is actually nearly defeated in this
fight beforehan solo turns up and
inevitably shoots first
laugh it up fuzzball the trooper in
question is known as fn2199 and the
webinar cemented the fact that
lightsabers on the field and end all of
Star Wars melee combats is a Z6 riot
control baton amazingly these non-lethal
weapons are standard issue fare for
first order riot control Stormtroopers
which explains why fn2199 happens to be
carrying a lightsaber level baton around
it also heavily implies that there are
many others like him around of course
Finn's not exactly an expert lightsaber
duelist at this point and no one's
saying that a well-trained Jedi couldn't
hold his own against the Baton wielding
Stormtrooper However the fact that such
a low-level first order grunts have
ready access to this level of gear
suggests that weapons like this are
mass-produced fare unlike lightsabers
which are notoriously few and far
between the combination of this weapons
comparatively wide availability and its
proven combat worthiness against
lightsabers arguably makes a Wyatt
control baton the superior product
[Music]